there are new details that are emerging
about the nearly 11 hour standoff at a
texas synagogue over the weekend
one of the four hostages rabbi charlie
citron walker said on facebook quote i
am grateful that we made it out i'm
grateful to be alive we feel the same
rabbi cbs news has learned that the
rabbi spoke with president biden
yesterday he joins us for an interview
you're seeing first on cbs mornings
rabbi good morning to you we are so glad
you're safe and able to be with us you
have no idea how happy we are to see you
this morning kudos to law enforcement
and negotiators that got you out and so
i want to know how you're processing all
of this i saw interviews with some of
your congregation over the weekend that
said it was terrifying just watching it
i can't imagine what it was like for you
and your fellow hostages to be there
well it was terrifying it was
overwhelming
uh and
we're still processing it's uh it's been
a lot it's
it's completely overwhelming
yeah you know i i saw interviews with
law enforcement officials who were
crediting you with being so calm and
collected during this time how were you
able to stay calm
when you're dealing with someone who
doesn't appear to mind dying
i guess you do what you have to do
as a part of
rabbinic training as a part of training
as as clergy we talk
a lot about the idea of being a calm
non-anxious presence
we do that in hospital rooms we do that
uh during the most difficult
of
individual moments and
i did the best i could
uh to
to do that in uh throughout the
throughout the stand
rabbi as we understand it the the
hostage taker knocked on the glass door
of the synagogue
and you thought he might need some
shelter so you let him in
made a cup of tea for him at what point
after that did things turn and you
realize he wasn't here for shelter
when i
when i took him in
i stayed with him uh making tea was an
opportunity for me to talk with him
and in that moment i didn't hear uh
anything suspicious
i
in
some of this story didn't quite add up
so i was a little bit curious but that's
not necessarily an uncommon thing
it was during prayer
while we were praying and my back was
turned we face towards jerusalem when we
pray
it
right right before
right before he revealed himself but
this was you know plenty of time in
i heard a click
and it could have been anything
and it turned out that it was his gun
were you and any of the other hostages
uh say that again please sorry were you
and any of the other hostages ever
physically hurt or threatened by this
man
did he harm you physically i guess we
we we were threatened the entire time
that we uh
no fortunately fortunately none of us
were were physically um injured
okay
you hear that click
that's got to be absolutely terrifying i
i've heard you say that the congregation
had
training
not that long ago for a situation where
someone drew a gun
uh and that that's what saved your life
how so
well so for the past few years uh we've
had training with uh
but it's not training it's i guess
courses
uh instruction uh with the fbi with the
colleybill police department with the
anti-defamation league
with secure communities network and
they
they really
teach you in those moments that
if you're when your life is threatened
you need to do whatever you can
to get to safety you need to do whatever
you can to get out
and rabbi is he was
oh go ahead
sorry
um
when
he
the last hour or so of the standoff
he wasn't getting what he wanted
he was getting
um it
it didn't look good it didn't sound good
we were
very
we were terrifying
and
when i saw an opportunity
um
uh where he wasn't in a good position
i asked made sure that the
two gentlemen who were still with me um
that they were
that they were ready to go
uh the exit wasn't too far away
i told them to go
i threw a chair at the gunman
and i headed for the door
and all three of us were able to get out
without even a shot being fired
rabbi it's amazing and you talk about
that training and that leading to some
of this you know for so many people when
we saw this headline we thought of
pittsburgh right away in the tree of
life and
i'm curious knowing how some people
there feel about going back
into their synagogue which they have not
done as a congregation have you thought
about going back to your congregation at
this point back into that building
oh of course it's uh it's something that
we are going to
that we're definitely going to do
unfortunately we've experienced
just great difficulty and challenges a
people
and at the same time
we've experienced great resilience
it
it won't necessarily be an easy thing
but it's a really important thing
uh and
a synagogue is a place it's called the
bait knesset
it's a it's a house of assembly it's
regather it's a place where we gather as
a community it's a place where we
where we pray together
and it's been really hard
since
you know some of the community was in
person i'm so grateful
that we only had a few people in person
and we had other people joining us
online
but the fact that it was
only a few of us had to experience all
of us experienced trauma but just a few
of us had to experience that level of
trauma
is just one of
so many things that i'm grateful for
well so many are grateful that you were
there with them obviously in that moment
in knowing what to do rabbi i know that
the jewish community and all faiths were
praying with you yesterday thank you
rabbi charlie citron walker we
appreciate you sharing your story
and and i and i just want to give thanks
and appreciation for
all of the love and all of the support
from
from the jewish community my people from
the muslim community from the christian
community from all faiths all
backgrounds
friends uh acquaintances strangers
all over the world it's it's it's truly
been overwhelming thank you so much
rabbi thank you so good to see you great
note to end